we're continuing our conversation with
Andrew Torres who's a graduate of
Harvard Law he's been practicing law for
21 years and he co-hosts the opening
arguments show the legal podcast that
helps you make sense of the news so
yesterday we spoke in part one of the
interview about net neutrality I want to
get your thoughts a little bit on the
robert muller investigation that's been
going on my non-lawyer interpretation of
how robert muller has been going about
this investigation is that he is doing
it in an incredibly competent way
systematically working through
interviews and documents early
indictments I would guess strategically
selected in order to maybe set up bigger
indictments down the line through the
use of leverage what's your sense of it
I mean do you get the same sense I do as
a general thing yeah and and so short
answer yes
but because you have a lawyer on the
show you're going to get a long answer
as well and and and I want to say as a
caveat I I'm a civil litigator I work
with startups and small businesses but
as the co-host of the opening arguments
show I started getting these questions
pretty much the day after Trump's
inauguration because there were sort of
very plainly criminal activities taking
place the most obvious was was the
president
naming Jared Kushner to the white house
staff it's a it's an obvious violation
of the anti-nepotism statute but the
only real remedy that we have is is the
rim Pietschmann so obviously that's kind
of the context for the Moller
investigation as it as it's going to
affect the president the president is
not going to be tried the question is
whether this is going to set up
appropriate swings in public opinion
such that Republicans come on board and
are willing to vote for impeachment and
with all that as background you hit the
nail exactly on the head the one thing I
tell people over and over again in my
conversations with prosecutors I worked
very closely with white-collar criminal
defense attorneys for 15 years
I have friends who were federal judges
in my experience and in my conversations
with them the one thing they tell me
over and over again is in a normal
non-political non media heavy case these
are two three year investigations it's a
slow process and again that that
dovetails with my experience in large
civil litigation you've got because you
know if you watch like you know law and
order TV shows you know you you flip
witnesses in twenty minutes and then get
them to testify these are as we as we've
seen from like the manna for indictment
that came down these are bad guys who
are associated with the inner circle of
the president and one of the questions
one of the duties that robert muller has
is to prosecute everybody who's
committed a crime while making the best
possible case against the ringleaders
and and all the way up to the office of
the president so take take manna fort
for example you might think that as a
matter of you know kind of law and order
type strategy oh we'll just give man
afford immunity and have him flip and
testify against the president and then
boom you're done but but part of what
Muller is trying to figure out is how
well can I make the case without having
to give man afford immunity because he's
committed uh uh again he's allegedly
committed according to the indictment
tens to hundreds of millions of dollars
in tax fraud in in except in in
laundering money from the Ukraine and
those are those are allegations I want
to be clear on that but if that's the
case and and clearly indictments were
handed down so Muller thinks that
there's a strong probability that that's
the case you need to you need to figure
out do I let somebody who has defrauded
the u.s. out of hundreds of millions of
dollars who I think has defrauded the
u.s. out of hundreds of millions of
dollars walk to make a political case
against the president and all of that
requires basically doing your homework
collecting as much information going
through it and if the
and the Republican strategy has been to
try and convince the public that it
should be the opposite right like oh
well we should have an answer by now and
the investigation should be done it's a
slow process so one of the common
talking points from the nothing to see
here crowd which exists on both the left
and right for different reasons but we
don't have to get into that aspect of it
today is listen David everything that's
coming out so far relates to possible
crimes that have nothing to do with
collusion between the Donald Trump
campaign and Russian actors it's
financial fraud committed before these
people Paul Manafort for example worked
for Trump or whatever the case may be
can we first define collusion itself is
not a crime so what sorts of specific
crimes might be possible under this
general umbrella of colluding with
Russia yeah so you're right and the
nothing to see here crowd is technically
correct that collusion isn't a crime but
what is a crime is conspiracy and and in
particular there's a statute it's 18 US
Code section 371 that is conspiracy to
defraud the United States and it's a
really really say it's a three-line
statute it says if two or more persons
conspire to commit any offense against
the United States or to defraud the
United States or any agency thereof for
any purpose and one or more of those do
any act to effect the conspiracy then
they've committed the crime and it's and
it carries up to it of a five year
prison sentence manna fort is charged
with conspiracy to defraud the US it's
true that a lot of the lot of the counts
relate to tax fraud as we've said but
but the idea that you would dismiss that
as not being significant is is kind of
beyond me and and I and I want to be
clear there's there are multiple cases
there's a Supreme Court case that goes
back to 1924 it's called hammerschmidt
the u.s. that explicitly says that
conspiracy to defraud the United States
includes a conspiracy to interfere with
or obscure
any lawful government function right and
free and fair elections are very very
plainly a lawful government function if
that wasn't clear then in 1996 you might
recall and this is you know sort of good
ammunition you know for the the Trump
supporting crowd there were allegations
that the Clinton the Bill Clinton
re-election campaign was receiving undue
influence from China with respect to the
1996 election there was a financier from
Little Rock named Charlie tree I was a
Clinton fundraiser and he was indicted
and pled guilty and he didn't plead
guilty to 18 USC 371 he people had
guilty to violations of election list
but he was charged under 18 USC 371 and
again in that case there was no evidence
that the Chinese attempt to interfere
went anywhere high up in the in the
Clinton campaign organization but it was
investigated and that was the the
statute that Republicans thought at the
time was appropriate to use if if a
foreign government was trying to
interfere with with a US election and
you know we took it seriously in 1996 we
should take it seriously now hey well
listen all of this gets me to the real
question which is when are we gonna lock
her up what it actually gets me to
though is is the different question
which is when you talked about this idea
of really the path forward if there are
big discoveries from this would be
political wins such that Donald Trump is
impeached or sort of forced to resign
what happens to Mike Pence in that
situation in other words does it just
become pence as president or what would
it take for pens to be as implicated as
Trump in whatever so so here's here's
the kind of lengthier answer that we do
we do a recurring segment on opening
arguments called yodel mountain and the
reason we call it that is because I was
asked that very question again you know
week one after Donald Trump assumed
office and in light of the of the Jared
Kushner appointment you know
what's it gonna take to impeach Donald
Trump and my answer was you know do you
remember the old prices right game with
the yodeler going up the mountain and
every time you missed by a dollar the
yodel would you know the little mountain
climber would would climb up and when
you missed by a total of so many dollars
he would reach the top of the mountain
and fall off and that's the way to think
about this sort of drip drip drip of
criminal activities right we know the
president has committed crimes already
we know that according to Republicans
it's not serious enough for them to
think that that those crimes are
impeachable there is a point where the
yodeler will fall off the mount there is
a point where that cumulative effect is
so great that even Republicans in safe
districts are gonna are going to turn on
the president obviously we're not there
yet now how does that affect Mike Pence
as far as I can tell there is no
evidence that connects Mike Pence up
with any of the public investigation to
date I would
wherever you put the probability of
Trump being impeached that you have to
set the probability of that applying to
Mike Pence at almost zero from from what
we know right now so you see you have to
be willing to say as and again I'm a
left-of-centre Democrat as somebody who
does not want to see Mike Pence be
present in the United States that I'll
accept that
I'll accept that outcome in order to not
have somebody in office who as far as I
can tell has no public service what so a
trite cares only about enriching himself
his immediate circle of cronies and his
friends yeah well now we're getting to
more of what I agree with is the
political analysis which is that yeah I
believe the best scenario for the left
is probably from staying not resigning
or being impeached riddled and scandal
unable to accomplish or at least able to
accomplish as little as possible and and
the public spectacle of that leading to
a major loss for both Trump and the
Republicans in 18 and 20 because I think
that if Mike Pence becomes president he
becomes
way less scandalous and his sort of
standard right-wing ideologue
perspective actually gets a lot of
really horrible stuff done I I I respect
that point of view that was the point of
view I held in January sort of pre you
know pre inauguration it it I have to
tell you I find it knowing right because
the predicate of what you've just said
is if Mike Pence is president we have a
much greater risk of aberrant political
policies being elected because Mike
Pence is not ridden by scandal and he is
a much more competent political
operative I'm willing to take that risk
in my plan again I understand how people
can come out differently I'm willing to
take that risk at this point because
Mike Pence is at least a career civil
servant right I disagree with his
definition of civil service but he has
he's somebody who operates within the
political process and I believe that he
will be deterred or believe that he has
a stronger chance of being deterred by
not engaging in blatantly illegal
conduct and not you know sort of setting
up these irresolvable conflicts then
then Trump is and and I think he cares
about things beyond just lining his
pockets and his and his family's pockets
it I get that it's a tough call but I
mean this is really you know as somebody
who's you know been here for two decades
and politically active four three like
this is not normal right it is not it's
not usual to have courts handing down
injunctions blocking executive orders at
eleven o'clock at night on a Thursday
right like it it is not usual to have
you know two competing courts issuing
two differing rulings on two
interpretations of statutes right this
is we've been we've been put into a
position that you know like we survive I
like a you know and again I was pretty
anti George W Bush but but you know we
survived that with our institutions
intact we survived George HW Bush we
survived Ronald Reagan I feel like this
is much more of an
an existential threat hard to argue
against that for sure we've been
speaking with Andrew Torres check out
the opening arguments show thanks so
much for talking to us Andrew we will
definitely do it again
David it's always fun to be on the show
thank thank you so much for having me on
having me back